[Music]  one of my best friends and here will be  absolutely one of the funniest people  live you're one of my best friends I  wish I could say the second your hand is  bigger you got a big old dick do you  have a big old dick and that's exactly  how I thought that the interview was  financed do you have a big old dick it  came to me in a dream no now I'm mostly  I'm mostly tip it's there's very little  shoutout it's not my cell tip there's a  lot it looks like looks like a  portobello mushroom fell on another type  of mushroom like a shiitake and see it's  it's it's like a stack of mushrooms like  a mushroom tower I can't believe I just  said that I don't think I don't know  what to do I think I might have to leave  the business I think we're leaving all  of it in TJ Miller everybody  [Applause]  [Music]